[Music]
thank you
Gus Carter The Spectators Deputy
features editor writes in this week's
magazine that men are in crisis to
explain he joins me now with Nina power
Economist at Compact magazine
Gus you write in the magazine that young
boys are in a bind tell us why
well I think the argument that I make in
the magazine is that young boys are
basically faced with a new form of
sexual politics which treats them as
though they're inherently dangerous to
girls and young women that treats them
as though they basically can't control
their instincts and we see this in
adverts on the tube there are signs that
say uh unwanted staring is sexual
harassment and that kind of thing but
there are also these groups going into
schools that are talking to young boys
and they're saying uh basically
masculinity is something that needs to
be changed and they're saying again we
need to stop violence against women and
girls all things that are you know
perfectly good and proper everyone
agrees with that I think the problem is
that is that in some ways the pendulum
is swung to such an extent that boys
feel like they can't express any form of
masculinity really Nina do you think
that young men in the west are being
unfairly vilified yeah I think we've
actually been seeing this for quite a
few years now it's often kind of a
media-led campaign to sort of divide the
Sexes and to present this kind of
um ongoing sense of Suspicion it's also
in the broader context of kind of
safetyism
um and I think also a kind of lack of a
general moral code sort of following the
the death of religion if you like so
nobody really knows how to behave with
each other anymore and I think this has
given rise as a kind of paranoia which
has largely been aimed at men and and as
Gus says they're sort of supposed or
purported inability to contain
themselves
and Gus where do you think the problem
is starting or I suppose stemming from
here because one thing she writing your
piece about is um what children being
told in schools so there's one example
of I think just a boy messaging a girl
and apparently that's a problem yes I
mean that's an extraordinary story from
a friend who's whose son is his son sort
of an English Day School uh and he
texted a girl from another school
basically just saying hello uh and he
was called up in front of the school
authorities to explain his behavior uh
for the uh criminal act of unsolicited
contact uh with a with a girl I think I
think the problem here is that
um you know children need to be exposed
to to uh different elements
all different parts of kind of adult
life right that's part of growing up
people need to learn how to have
relationships people need to learn how
to deal with the kind of messiness of of
human life and what we're doing is we're
denying children that opportunity and I
think it's turning them into into
slightly kind of uh scared sad and
withdrawn individuals and I think it's a
problem particularly with boys but I
mean I mean Nina Nina made the point
that uh that that it's kind of pitting
the Sexes against each other that's
totally true I mean you know this isn't
an argument that that somehow uh you
know girls or women are mistreating men
that isn't it at all it's more a kind of
culture as Nina says of of safetyism
and then on that do you think that what
we're seeing here is when we talk about
rebranding masculinity is there a risk
at least some of the people saying that
is just almost ending masculinity and
replacing it more with femininity
yeah I I think that that's definitely
happening and it goes alongside the kind
of feminization of the economy as well
and the sort of devaluing of sort of
traditionally or typically male
interests and talents and skills
um so that everyone almost is being
pushed towards becoming more more
feminine which isn't good for men and it
isn't good for women either actually
um so that we end up with this kind of
totally proximate society in which men
and women are kind of almost like
siblings rather than in any uh more
interesting relation let's say of like
compatibility or companionship or
um you know like complementarity you
know we don't we don't kind of think of
the relationship between men and women
um in that way very often which is which
is unfortunate because in a way that is
what we need to get along you know
whether it's as friends or as as married
couples or you know and that there's not
enough value or time given to that to
those kind of um relations I think and
Gus I suppose on that we can talk about
uh those who've got plenty examples in
your piece who are
um ultimately in a way you could argue
trying to end masculinity as opposed to
um rebranding and what their real motive
is but of course you also have concerns
and perhaps what we see more in the
media that there is something called
talks masking into so for example if you
look at Andrew Tate that is someone that
head teachers have been really concerned
about
um they think you know lots of uh you
know you ask your average person on the
street they might not know who that
person is or they may now have recent
stories and but yet that person was very
well known amongst pupil age and it is
teaching boys bad attitudes do you think
there's a problem then I suppose with uh
on the side of messenger that there are
some people who are putting forward a
toxic version of it oh totally I totally
agree with that I mean you know if you
look at some of the things Andrew Tate
says they're just I mean totally
objectionable that you know it's not an
argument about about defending people
like Andrew Tate but I but I think I
think what's happened is that is that
you've had other people people like uh
Jordan Peterson people like Joe Rogan
who do exude a form of a form of
masculinity and put forward a kind of
vision of masculinity and those people
are treated as kind of extremists too I
think you can disagree with people like
like Jordan Peterson I certainly don't
think he's an extremist but part of the
problem is when you treat those kinds of
people in that way you give rise to a to
a kind of to an even kind of further
more extreme kind of thing about it yeah
exactly exactly and I think that's part
of the problem you know I mean it's one
of those things that's that's kind of
that's often decried in the media the
fact that there aren't you know very
many male role models anymore but when
they do pop up I mean they are they are
kind of ruthlessly attacked and and so
the boys you know go looking for
something even more kind of extreme and
mental uh Nina do you agree with that
yes I mean I would say someone like
Andrew Tate
um could be seen as a kind of symptom
you know he's subversive and attractive
precisely because partly he's saying
things that you're not really allowed to
say according to the mainstream dominant
regime ideology
um you know which isn't to defend Andrew
Tate at all and I think you know I agree
with um Gus in the sense that even very
moderate and Mild
um positions like Jordan Peterson's
which is basically fundamentally telling
young men to sort of sort themselves out
and stop blaming the world and women for
their problems and just get things in
order which is you know really kind of
basic stuff but you know delivered in
this kind of patrician 1950s absent
father figure which I think is a big
part of the problem
um kind of way and I I think what's
what's generally missing is the question
of virtue like there isn't enough room
to say what does it mean to be a good
man right so figures like men like Tate
are presenting well this is how you get
on in the world through status and and
being I don't know really quite uh and
unpleasant
um but what we really need is just kind
of men
um well the possibility for men and
young boys to be good rather than this
kind of fundamental assumption that
there's something wrong with men or that
you know boys and men are fundamentally
badly aligned or you know which which
can't be the case right if we want to
get on together we have to allow that
both men and women are moral agents as
well and so therefore we can talk about
what it means to be a good man of what
it means to be a good woman
um and what it means to be together in a
better way basically Nina I'm really
interested in your point about about
virtue and about ethics I think there
was an interesting item in in Charles
Moore's notes last week when he pointed
to uh and this is a bit of a kind of
side comment but uh uh where where he
pointed to the Civil Service where
they're hiring kind of Ethics officers
and there's almost this sense of of kind
of ethics and virtue being something
that's done by Specialists now rather
than something that we all have to deal
with in our own lives and when you do
that when you remove it something else
is going to come in and fill the Gap we
just don't we just kind of don't even
think about it in in moral terms
no exactly it's a total absence you know
and I think it's part of being in a kind
of post-christian
um very mixed world that's also filled
with very contradictory imperatives like
if you know young men are often watching
a lot of pornography I mean that gives
you a vision of the world which is like
overwhelmingly sexual you know and a lot
of young men then start to see the world
in that way you know exhibit and
experience shame they can't interact
normally
um but we need a much more kind of
integrated culture that says look
they're all these things you could
possibly do but some of them are
actually bad for you and they're bad for
society as a whole you know we don't try
we don't tend to think in that kind of
socially integrated way we we think that
everything is an individual decision
because and that desire is good and
whatever people want is good
um but this is this selfishness this
selfish Society
um yeah completely mitigates against any
Collective project
um of virtue
so Gus watching the answer is here when
it comes to stopping this group feeling
uh as low they are being isolated or and
they've been pushed you know further in
a certain direction is it less
interference I don't really know it's
it's I kind of didn't get into it in the
piece and I almost did that on purpose
because I don't know what the answers
are I think if there was someone here uh
kind of disagreeing with me and Nina
they would be saying but hang on there's
a there's a huge problem with with
sexual assault you know I talk to my
female friends and they say you don't
realize what it's like to sit on the to
sit on the tube on your own you know
you're constantly bombarded by by men
you know behaving inappropriately and I
and I I totally understand that it seems
like a very seems like a very difficult
problem to solve I think I think part of
the way of doing it though is is
allowing people the space to kind of
make mistakes almost so the woman that
started everyone's invited uh which is
the movement that kind of led to a lot
of these uh like Boyhood initiatives and
uh you know a lot of discussions about
toxic masculinity uh and it came about
because uh there were a lot of uh
accusations of sex assault at kind of uh
big English private schools she said
when she launched it she didn't want it
to become kind of cover for for cancel
culture she didn't want she didn't want
children to be kind of attacked for
making mistakes she just said she wanted
people to recognize that there was a
problem and and you know in order to in
order to kind of better deal with it but
it shouldn't have been a kind of cancel
culture thing and I think I think maybe
that's that's where we're going wrong
you know I mean there's a there's an
example I use in the piece of a School
in Essex where they've totally banned
children from having any romantic
relationships from even from even
touching each other even hugs and that's
clearly a sign of a of a you know of an
institution that's that's terrified of
you know of people making mistakes of
people getting upset people being
unhappy that's part of being in
relationships
and you know I suppose on Gus's point
which is you know lots of people will
say well look at all these examples in
the past in terms of Men Behaving Badly
um you look at harassment rates and so
forth
um you do need to have the way to stop
this is to you know try and stem the
problem early on Hensley's talks in
schools
um so what would you say to them
yeah I think it's it's I agree with Gus
that there's this kind of we have to
allow people to make mistakes I mean we
all make mistakes and a lot of things
are not badly intended right you know
there's obviously a difference between
somebody kind of intentionally
um
of setting somebody or or behaving in a
way that's kind of uh clearly goes
against their wishes but most of the
time in a lot a lot of these kind of
interactions especially among teenagers
they're more Awkward than badly intended
I think and you know to lump everything
in together is and to kind of
infantilize everyone and keep them
protected and keep them safe isn't going
to allow people to become mature and
become adult which is partly uh arrived
at through making mistakes and that goes
for girls and boys as well you know I
mean it's not only boys uh making
mistakes
um so I think yeah we're going to end up
with a kind of culture of of permanent
children who are sort of very scared and
over protected um and I think this isn't
really the way to seed it doesn't set
you up for dealing with the reality of
life and it's inevitable suffering in
fact trying to keep people from
suffering actually makes them suffer
more right so I you know again it's a
very complicated uh question I mean I
read um uh Soma Sarah's book and and
looked at the everyone's invited project
um and really the only conclusion you
could draw from the kind of terrifying
paint picture that she paints of what
it's like to be at schools is to to go
to single sex schools and to keep boys
and girls completely segregated until
they're about 21 or something I mean
it's really what she's describing as a
kind of horrific environment filled with
uh you know uh boys just completely
influenced by pornography and you know
it that may be worse that may be worse
than it was when we were at school
um you know I'm not going to deny that
you know having porn on your phone is is
maybe more uh you know of course it's a
different it's a different world in some
ways
um but I think the conclusion uh can't
necessarily be that kind of total
segregation you know then we're back to
almost like a religious Society uh
almost a theocracy and we might need
better ways of of young men and women
spending time together we might need
more
um thought about what rituals we have
right but I think we're looking at a
very
um kind of imbalanced picture either
total segregation or this kind of
liberal free-for-all
um and neither of which seem
particularly satisfying I was going to
say Nina on your on your point about
infantilization uh and about making
people more anxious by trying to stop
them from suffering I think we kind of
risk going into a bit of a a bit of a
death spiral here in a way because and
I'm going to say something quite kind of
controversial but I think uh I think
part of the problem is that there's been
a massive expansion in the definition of
what of what kind of sexual misconduct
is in the first place so if you look at
um if you look at statistics on sex
assault in schools uh from about 10 15
years ago it's much much lower than the
figures uh were in 2021 and I think part
of that is because definitions are
changing and definitions are expanding
and then that and then that seems to
almost encourage uh this kind of culture
to go further if you see what I mean
yeah for sure
and Gus just finally
we're obviously at a period where um
we're still talking about school boys
particularly we've had the pandemic
which has meant even less social
interaction than these people would have
normally I think as Nina was touching on
um if you are you know lurking in chat
rooms watching porn and you're not
actually speaking to people
um this idea you know that is one form
of segregation and of itself do you
think
um despite all these attempts to almost
keep boys and girls separate that more
interaction is actually the answer to
normalize these relationships oh totally
uh and it's a form of self
self-segregation uh it's the boys kind
of kind of withdrawing themselves I
think because of uh because of this
feeling that they can't really get
anything right at all it's a lot easier
to just sit in your bedroom for you know
most of your teens and 20s you know
you're not going to get in trouble with
anyone uh you sat there having a rather
sad life sat in your bed um one of the
people I speak to in the piece is a is a
child psychologist called Julie Lynn
Evans and when I spoke to her she said
uh the problem here is that um is that
boys and girls are being kind of pitted
against each other and
um girls are being told boys are
dangerous boys are being told you know
you're a danger unto yourself and others
uh and actually it's it's just it's
untrue and it's unhelpful the girls want
boyfriends as much as the boys want
girlfriends and you know if we're going
to continue as a society people need to
you know get married have kids that's
how we that's how we continue as a
species
it's also important to the future of
mankind yeah exactly exactly thank you
Gus thank you Nina for joining spectator
TV
[Music]
foreign